tenere tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo sud e
forrest gump ho ricevuto la beta key di
the forest circa 5 10 minuti fa e sono
contentissimo probabilmente uno dei
videogame che stava aspettando da da un
casino di tempo non ci ho ancora giocato
infatti non vedo l'ora di iniziare però
più o meno di cosa si tratta quindi non
giuro vedrete mai fatto questi tizi si
stanno limando in una maniera tipo sexy
ragazzi iniziamo anche se non vedo la
[ __ ] ora di vedere come fa ecco ci
siamo
ma che bello specie casa mia ragazzi
aperta è come cameriera una chicca messo
un marmocchio sul mio braccio togliti
dai [ __ ]
c'è uno che dorme scorso
forse questa è un'anomalia
non credo che il volo debba andare così
però non ne sono sicuro magari fa parte
del viaggio e non è che cazzo cazzo
be nice ok tranquilli ragazzi per miglio
parcheggio così di solito io parcheggio
così nino non c'è niente di cui
preoccuparsi perfetto dove che cazzo
successo salve ma lei fa make up
c'è un no che cazzo è mio colpo
all'occhio pranzo mi ami ami ha preso il
marmocchio no dove vai tu nudo fermo
ragazzi mi ha [ __ ] il bambino mi era
sul mio braccio brutto stronzo non sotto
è che siamo sono un po sporco non mi
chiedete come ho fatto a sopravvivere ad
uno schianto aereo perché non noi da
nemmeno io comunque cerco di prendere le
provviste perché devo sopravvivere
ve lo spiego dai la praticamente sarebbe
un gioco di sopravvivenza tutti schianti
con una era in mezzo alla foresta c'è un
coniglio appello di zio vieni qua no no
bastardo di me doveva io in te ragazzi
da tramite tutti gli schianti in una
foresta a caso è il sapore st ci sono
dei tizi nudi che foto nei bambini non
senti signora posto cortesemente
prendere questa cha conficcata nel suo
stomaco grazie mille ragazzi dove cazzo
siamo finiti che non ho capito ho
parcheggiato bene non c'è male a ragazzi
a parte il fatto che sto gioco è una
figata pazzesca è che ha fatto un
accampamento qua dietro
che ci siamo schiantati su un
accampamento che sfiga di merda ci siamo
schiacciati con un aero ci sono dei
morti li a destra cazzo non può andare
peggio di così a meno che non piova e la
cosa mi spaventa perché comunque no
vabbè dai vi state prendendo per il culo
brutto stronzo
eccoti qua [ __ ] eccolo qua
rilanciato uccello di menta è colpa tua
non voglio ragazzi sto buttando giù un
albero a caso credo
no no cazzo cazzo ok mi so se sono vivo
sono vivo ci sono le valigie chiuse
afferma chi se ne fotte c'è un ascia
porca [ __ ] mai voi così ho mica era
difficile anche perché non ancora ma una
pallina da tennis perfetto non ho da
mangiare né un rifugio però posso
giocare a tennis è una cosa che cosa
faccia in un malore al braccio cosa non
ha fatto è che ora ragazzi delle sementi
birdies vi insegnerà come sopravvivere
le foreste una volta che ci si è
schiantata con un aereo da prima cosa
fare non prendere freddo quindi non
bagnarsi ma tanto piano e quindi
[ __ ] e dopodiché bisogna pescare
un pesce una canna
ma che cazzo fate ragazze per caso molto
nel caso fosse discusso morirei di fame
ma se c'è oppure su un pesce dimenati
brutto stronzo tanto vinto io ho vinto
io
una volta trovato il pesce dovete andare
ragazzi a cucinarlo come si deve quindi
due cazzo andato ai ragazzi vediamo di
trovare un rifugio dei cento almeno
bianco se oggi abbiamo piu nella merda
ricordo pensasse
altro che lost questo è peggio è una
cosa
sì ma se te strozzi allora non importa
tanto abbiamo capito che piove quindi
non c'è più non c'è problema voglio
avere un attimo esplorare per vedere che
cosa cosa fosse quella roba da più è una
è una bottiglia che cazzo di schermo non
lo sapesse controllare ma vabbè io io
napulitane la darei comunque linee nel
dubbio ragazzi c'è o non c'è un altra
tenda che non ha mai ma sono solo qui
non so secondo me non sono sopra che
c'era un nudo prima quindi probabilmente
c'è del vodka a noi che ci permetta alle
noci con dischi panini nel mcdonald's e
nike 6 st ancora che cazzo ci fa ora un
del podio a mano a ma mi fermi come uno
squalo e uno scompenso fosse un delfino
non mai giocato una roba così fantastica
il cazzo sono quelli le grappe gazich e
della gente c'è della gente brutta io me
dire in pace yo yo fa vigenza salve
salme dei lei è nudo vero molto piacere
è un paio di pantaloni io sceglierei che
cazzo fai affanculo ecco da son cazzi
tuoi perché mi ha attaccato non nomino
per le fa questo dio si può suicidare in
mezzo alla cosa fai
no no cazzo devi morire e devi morire tu
e tua sorella è [ __ ] mai marie
maurice non muore
mi chiamo il tu sei brutto ragazzi sta
infilando un pizzo da mezz'ora ma non
muore brutto passando che stanno
attaccando degli indigeni è una cloud
day may day use vista attaccando della
gente che non conosco e che cos'è babbi
e vieni qui basta pieni gli eco nascosto
nostro di merda vieni qui non andate
affanculo fu 6 2 avete rotto il cazzo mi
hanno ascoltato ma che nasce mià io ti
butto giù stronzo alla docente e butto
giù come se non ci fosse un domani
stronzo non dovevi permetterti di
toccarmi ma franco case in scena lurido
pezzo di strada
no no no sto morendo cazzola fa qualcuno
anche a tema perché ragazzi sono morto
non so dove cazzo si apre monete che
cazzo è successo oddio
rega che in jazz e ragazzi dove cazzo
siamo finiti è una casa oddio ragazzi
sono in fin di vita in una caverna
sperduta non so dove
e c'è gente appesa al soffitto è una
cosa normale e non penso non accendo
cimino è la ciellina bravo almeno che
funzioni quello c'è un braccio a terra o
che si è vista oggi bengala pisa lockeed
ragazzi ho trovato credo che questa
riesca a distrarre qualcuno credo almeno
se passa una nave possa avvertirli credo
poi c'è anche una rivista ragazzi che si
piazza la gente però stanno attenti ai
costi pensi mi ci mancherebbe casa cosa
ceca io io figlio tutto se salve io vado
è stato un piacere grazie mille a come
si esce di qua di preci di qua andare di
qua immigrati grazie mille ragazzi non
so dove stiamo andando
dove sono finiti qui io io ero rimasto
che picchiamo degli indigeni poi non so
non so dove documenti sono arrivati qui
ma non importa è la casa che cosa sta
succedendo
c'è una disco perché lampeggia tutta non
siamo sotto nella caverna encore madonna
quante grossa st caverna la gamma di
preciso chi cazzo mi ha portato qui dato
quel invitano delle palle ci scommetto
quello che volete
è una cazzo prezzo ok ok ok ok anche
anche come non detto
come ho detto vi abbia via via roccazzo
via
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no ok si sono spaventate si
sono spaventati di formica persone
infarto regalo shamo regalo usciamo
pulsioni qui come cazzo fatto come fai a
essere stanco e fatto due metri [ __ ]
diventa un divieto mi vedo più fondi
vedo che noi non frega niente via via
via via via vere c'è gente ancora pesa
basta ragazzi agli 8 usciamo di qui
veloce apri apri come sia questa m via
ovvero no no non mi serve questa per
miss abitazione grazie grazie mille ok
brutta così si si si si
sul sito sono si sono uscito canigiani
canicani l'ho vista brutta
l'ho vista veramente brutta rega è
sorpreso il cazzo di infarto regola
numero uno della sopravvivenza in
foresta se sei vedete lenin vigiani
lasciate di merda è stata una cosa
orribile regala apriva inter l'obiettivo
sarebbe quello di costruirmi un rifugio
e sopravvivere alla notte senza che
quella brutta gente mimì misto pri
ragazzi costruiamo del campamento prima
possibile perché la vedo veramente
brutta quei cosa clicca
no no no no cos'è oddio ha proposto fra
grazie mil come ho fatto a libertà no
vabbè dai micali me questo è
l'inventario più figo che abbia mai
visto che ho anche dei soldi possono
essere usati per il crafting è certo
perché torniamo ci pulisco il culo
seriamente come si fanno le cose
premo il tasto b eccolo qua a perfetto
shelters la prima prima facciamo un
fuoco decente a great place
anzi con i phone o vada è bellissimo mi
metto metto un coso qui mettono colloqui
perfetto che bisogna riempirlo con l
allora mi manca un ramo e poi ho finito
di fare fuoco non lo prendo un ramo
prendo acqua ok alla miglior se si può
prendere questo qui credo vada bene dai
sikh azzo grandi se adesso accendiamo
accendiamo con l'accendino no perché noi
siamo veramente tecnologici perfetto
ragazzi prima regola di sopravvivenza
fare un poco anche del cazzo ma fatelo
poi non serve una sega perché piove però
almeno a far fate vedere che siete figli
allora ragazzi la casa da faccio la
sopra mentre rifugio vedo se gli scopi a
farlo qui in un ramo cielo me
i nostri ragazzi meglio di perdere
scazzo ho deciso di fare al rifugio 4
sulla spiaggia ragazzi almeno se passa
qualcuno lo vedo andiamo andiamo a
lavorare e poi la casa me la farò più
avanti perché sennò è un caso
presto diverta dov'è dove hanno preso
nota affanculo marchiato nou dove vieni
qui lo prete lo prezzo carne fresca allo
ragazzi la smetti di giocare con gli
uccelli to testa di minchia qualche
questo si diverte che se grazie a dio
si vabbè ma che cazzo copre sta roba
perfetto perfetto mica sto facendo anche
il fuoco così ci siamo mai così mica
sono un fenomeno alla ragazzi ho
costruito ho costruito sta roba che
dovrebbe essere un rifugio posso anche
dormirci io avrei un po di paura a
dormire qua dentro quei tizi che girano
come cazzo di fare ma non importa
proviamoci lo stesso avremo z ok
perfetto scaccia e sociale è diventata
notte che il mio c'è un arcobaleno che i
ragazzi torniamo di nuovo perché sennò è
un problema se quella roba lì per un
attimo che devo vedere cose con la roba
ragazzi c'è una cazzo di già posso
scappo di temi che possono scappare vi
prego
ok scrivessero con barattoli qualcosa
non lo so posso che possono spuntare
quei tizi regala qualche parte di sicuro
mi stanno osservando c'è una zattera c'è
una cazzo di zattera dai bus
no non mi dite che è distrutto porca
[ __ ] l'unica sub speranza di
sopravvivenza distrutta fantastico siamo
così i ragazzi imposto da emissioni cosa
mia non so cosa fare la prossima volta
andrò a controllare checa successo la
montagna perché mi ispira un casino
comunque per ora vediamo di tornare a
diffuso prima che gli stupri qualcuno e
non me ne accorgo madonna regalo lost in
confronto era una merda
c'è un tizio ragazzi c'è un tizio con
una torcia vi prego ditemi che non sono
indigeni hanno una torcia cazzo ma fan
indigeni non ditemi che non sono
indigeni prego prega yo yo yo non mi
abbia ho paura che siano indigeni non lo
so perché non lo vedo ma non voglio
l'ami per scoprirlo quindi me ne vado
però non ha torcia cazzo come fanno ad
avere una torcia
ma da che cosa fanno il bagno a
mezzanotte va be calm i cani che mi un
attimo ci sono indizi sono indice di
perché sono nudi sinistra dove dove
l'avete messo il mio marmocchio bastardi
no meta molto amata ma la domanda che
cosa ragazzi direi che possono chiudere
che in questo episodio perché mi piace
lasciarvi in suspense che la la cosa
[ __ ] questo gioco non è cioè non è che
ha una storia tipo out as che devi
seguire questo gioco stava cretu la
storia e la è la cosa è stupenda regala
mostra cosa c'è anche a parte gli
infarti però va a parte quello direi che
posso continuare le prossime piste
ragazzi come al solito servizio è
piaciuto al suo documento mi piace anche
a pagani facebook che come non divida
tra descrizione ricordatevi che domani
uscirà lo speciale 750 mila iscritti
quindi non perdetevelo che noi ci
vediamo un prossimo video bella ragazzi